wenn man gasmangel und dann meinen
Ölmangel warum haben wir denn wir haben
den Angriffskrieg der Russen gegen die
Ukraine das ist das eine wir haben
reagiert mit inzwischen im achten
sanktions Paket ach sanktions Pakete man
kann ja durchaus sagen man geht an die
Oligarchen dran und lass die erstmal
fahren und wie schlagen aber was nicht
geht ist das Maßnahmen trifft die die
eigene Bevölkerung mehr treffen als das
Land ist man treffen will wir haben
erstmal eine Leitung die fertig waren
das war 192 nicht im Betrieb genommen
wir haben jetzt und es ist das aktuelle
Thema in Schwedt eine eine eine
graffinerie dort gibt's nur eine Leitung
Öl liefern konnte zur Zeit das ist die
leitbar wenn die Leitung jetzt von uns
gekappt wird wenn wir jetzt sagen wir
wollen kein Öl mehr aus Russland und es
ist jetzt so ab dem ersten Januar dann
wird es dazu dass nach wie vor
vollkommen unsicher ist ob diese
Raffinerie und mit welchen mit welchem
Level weiter betrieben werden die
Maßnahmen die uns immer im
energieausschuss und dem Klimaschutz
erzählt werden die sind immer
Absichtserklärung man will da künftig
Wasserstoff machen ist auch richtig aber
es löst es unmittelbare Problem nicht
sondern es gibt jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten
die eine geht über Danzig die andere
geht über Rostock aber es ist nach wie
vor nicht gesichert bis heute nicht
gesichert obwohl man abschaltet dass sie
die Raffinerie so weiter betrieben
werden kann und jetzt aufs Hauptproblem
ich sage
wenn wir Gas und und Öl brauchen und
keine Alternative haben oder von anderen
Farben schädigen das kaufen müssen dann
dann dann ist es sinnvoll diese Leitung
Nordstemmen 2 die in einem Strang noch
funktioniert zwei sind weggesprengt dann
behauptet ja von den Russen dann werden
ja saugen wenn Sie eine eigene Leitung
wegbringen würden ne diese verlangt das
glaubt ja auch bloß einer der im
Klammerbeutel gepudert ist sondern es
gibt insgesamt trotzdem eins und es gibt
trotzdem eins ist zerstört trotzdem zwei
ist noch eine Leitung gut sind zwei
Strecke man könnte die sofort machen
werden 37 Milliarden Kubikmeter Gas die
man in einem Jahr beziehen könnten wir
hätten das Problem nicht mehr und wir
hätten die Nachfrage sozusagen wieder
ein Stück weit an die oder andere das
Angebot wieder so erhöht dass der Preis
singt das heißt für dieses für diesen
Missstand den sie haben den die Bürger
haben in diesem Lande und das ist die
Kritik an der Bundesregierung ist diese
Bundesregierung verantwortlich weil die
sind ja die eigenen die eigenen
Sanktionen
eins möchte nur die eigene sind die
eigenen Sanktionen und zwar über das was
die EU beschlossen hat hinausgehen denn
andere Länder die an dieser
fußballleitung zum Beispiel hängen wie
die auch nach Schwedt geht Ungarn und so
die sind ausgenommen ist die die
Europäische Union hat gesagt wir nehmen
leitungsgebundenes Erdöl aus von
Sanktionen nur über Schiffe ist
übrigens auch die Schiffe vielleicht
auch mal darüber wird Katastrophe der
Preis weiter steigen macht
dann liefern die heute weniger und dann
steigt der Preis für richtig aber hören
Berti Vogts genau
ja es ist ein Dilemma es ist ein Dilemma
einerseits stimmt es natürlich ich habe
es ja vorhin gesagt ich kann mich jetzt
nicht widersprechen wenn es mehr Angebot
gibt dann sinkt der Preis das ist ja
völlig klar und wenn wir jetzt also von
allen Scheich dieser Welt und von allen
Potentaten dieser Erde Energie beziehen
wird für uns auch billiger die
Anfahrtswege werden kürzer wir haben
hier mehr zu verteilt nur haben sie
natürlich
genau nur wenn sie jetzt deutlich teurer
Amerikaner
verdienen die über 100 Millionen Euro
kaufen ist teuer
geworden trotzdem zwei wieder zu öffnen
und da wird man natürlich doch auf sehr
unmittelbar direkt Weise auch Potenz
kriegst Kasse füllen und das darf nicht
mehr
für eine Rechnung aber nicht außen vor
lassen das ist viel bei ihnen ist
überhaupt
warum weil keiner in dieser
Bundesregierung hat gesagt wir dürfen es
aus Nordstemmen eins nicht nehmen das
Gas im Gegenteil wir jammern jetzt dass
unsere Russland nichts mehr liefert und
und sagen das ist eigentlich eine
korrekt dass die das nicht tun weiter
abhängig machen von Russland und ihm
auch noch Russland kommt
an diesen Boykottmaßnahmen die wir
gemacht haben verdient denn der am
besten für das beste Unternehmen zur
Zeit ist gastron die die Leitungen ja
betreibt die haben jetzt schon an diesen
bekommt man es noch nicht verdient und
im übrigen den Gas ist es egal ob durch
eins oder doch trotzdem zwei kommt
trotzdem kaputt
Verantwortung haben dass sie ihre
Entscheidung verantworten können ist es
eben nicht egal würde von abraten jetzt
die Nordstern zweite Debatte zu öffnen
und den Zuge dessen danach auch wieder
die aufzutreten trotzdem also komplett
falsch bezahlt
es ist ja schon bezahlt der verkaufte es
nur anderweitiger verdient weitergehen
das Problem ist wir müssen langfristig
raus aus fossiler Energie wir würden
langfristig so oder so rausgegangen aus
fossiler Energie aus Russland da geht es
andere Möglichkeiten gegeben nur jetzt
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt sich selbst mit
einer mit dieser Maßnahme als Wirtschaft
zu schaden dieses übrigens nicht nur
kurzfristiger Akt wir werden langfristig
als Bundesrepublik Deutschland gegenüber
den Vereinigten Staaten
wesentlich an Konkurrenzfähigkeit
verlieren dort ist es die Energiepreis
ungefähr ein Zehntel von dem was er bei
uns ist und das bedeutet wir haben eine
Verschiebung der Industrie jetzt machen
die auch noch ein
riesenwirtschaftsprogramm
ja und was heißt es bei uns wird die die
Industrie geradezu aufgefordert das Land
zu verlassen und dorthin zu gehen
insbesondere Energie intensiver
Unternehmen
einmal aufbereitet haben das Problem
für Deutschland sind top in die Strom
teilweise in die Benzinpreise überall
sind wir ganz oben mit dabei steuern
genau dann noch rentenabzüge also im
Endeffekt meridiankommen sind wir glaube
ich eine der geringsten oder in Europa
bleibt so wenig von Bruttolohn den
größten niedrigeren Sektor in Europa und
auch mit die höchste Steuerabgabe
50%
wir haben die Bundesregierung gefragt in
einer offiziellen Anfrage wie wirken die
Sanktionen die wir machen wissen Sie was
die Bundesregierung das wissen sie nicht
die Bundesländer
so und dann fragt ihr dann noch im Jahr
fragt man den haben wir jetzt ein Jahr
ungefähr vielleicht eine 7 x 98 rechnen
dann sagt er ja ich weiß nicht ob das
gewirkt hat aber ich gebe dir jetzt mal
mehr
muss man einfach sagen her mit allem
egal auf welchem Preis dafür füllen oder
nicht
meine Position sondern meine Position
die Wirtschaft Sanktionen die gegen uns
richten die mehr den eigenen Bevölkerung
treffen als die russische Kriegskasse
die müssen wir stoppen die wir schaffen
also das was jetzt alles gesagt wird das
ist das erinnert mich immer mehr an an
Selbstmord an Selbstmordgedanken das ist
einfach Wahnsinn wenn ich mir das
reinziehe und das geht auf der breiten
Front so und wenn jemand
selbstmordgefährdet ist dann braucht er
vielleicht mal Hilfe und diese Regierung
scheint ja wirklich dringend Hilfe zu
brauchen und da fällt mir auch nichts
anderes ein also deutlich mal zu
sprechen weil
auf der unteren Ebene weiß man nicht
mehr wie man es machen soll und man hat
braucht dringend Hilfe und auch ja in
deinem Betrieb fragt man sich wie soll
es weitergehen und dann sieht man
ständig solche sanktionspakete das achte
Sanktionspaket und dann weiß man nicht
mal was es bringt also da muss ich doch
mal muss ich noch mal fragen ob man da
vielleicht die Leute nicht mal kündigt
wurde Lösungen ich möchte einmal bitte
sagen
aber man muss bei dieser Debatte auch
immer wieder das haben sie am Anfang
ganz am Anfang gesagt muss auch in
Rechnung stellen dass wir immer noch
mittendrin in einem Krieg in Europa und
dann gibt es einzig allein aus einem
Grund weil Russland Ukraine überfallen
hat Punkt Ende Gelände und alles was wir
versuchen jetzt mal besser mal
schlechter vielleicht auch mal
kontraproduktiv das kann ich gar nicht
abstellen ist versucht darauf zu
reagieren oder verstehen jetzt doch vor
einem schwierigen sehr schwierigen
Winter in der Ukraine mit vielleicht
entsetzlichem Leid und jetzt in dieser
Situation zu sagen machen wir trotzdem
eins und zwei wieder aufhalte ich für
sehr sehr trotzdem einziges kaputt
sozusagen ein Strang bei 1922
ist das durch das was wir tun durch
unsere Sanktionen hat Russland
unheimlich verdient durch den hohen
Ölpreis nee
wird gefüllt durch unsere deutlich
gemacht aber die Frage war ja
interessant
angeht ich hätte auch nichts dagegen
dass man natürlich selbstverständlich
keine Kriegswaffen mehr liefert die die
Ukraine Russland erstmal weil wir haben
ja die ausgerichtete ganze Ausbildung
dort aufgebaut natürlich
und jetzt komme ich zur Ukraine da halte
ich jetzt mit macron
verhandeln der hat vorgestern einen
Vorschlag gemacht der von der
politischen Klasse in der Bundesrepublik
sofort abgelehnt wurde das ist
unverantwortlich sowas abzulehnen ich
hatte mir gesagt man muss wenn wir den
Krieg beenden will die
Sicherheitsinteressen aller
berücksichtigen
Interessen Russland und die
Voraussetzung das ist nicht weiter zu
Toten und
unerträglichem Leid kommt übrigens für
beide Seiten auch für die die dort in
diesem äh in diesem besetzten Gebieten
sozusagen Leben ist dass dieser Krieg
beendet wird und der wird nur durch
Verhandlungen beendet
entschuldigen
Sie dass man sich mit Putin ein
Angriffskrieg führt der ein Land
überfallen hat an einen Tisch setzen
kann und verhandeln kann
also grundsätzlich Krieg ist nie schön
und keiner wünscht sie Krieg und das
sowas bei uns überhaupt mal vorkommt
hätte niemand gedacht ich frage mich nur
warum sie so unterscheiden zwischen den
Angriff von Putin jetzt an in die
Ukraine und zum Beispiel dann aber sagen
ja frechen Gas von die Amis können wir
nehmen aber die Arme ist der größte
Kriegstreiber sind auf der Welt also da
hat man komische
überleben also an der Stelle wirklich
importiert ich habe nur gesagt wir
importieren lieber das und verbieten uns
hier eine Debatte über frecken-gewinnung
in Deutschland nachzudenken das war mein
Punkt und ich glaube schon man muss der
darf diese Frage nicht aus dem Weg gehen
wie will man über diesen Frieden über
diesen Krieg verhandeln wenn die Ukraine
momentan sagt wir sind in keiner
Situation in der wir verhandeln können
wieder an diesen Stellvertreter kriegen
natürlich nein
die einzige wirklich große die die
einzigen die wirklich an diesem Bild
weiter ja klar wir kaufen ihnen
einfach Ihr Thema jetzt anfangen